[SPEAKER_02]: Second of Wales Sun, around 3 p.m. as Jude and Paul begin their journey.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, basically, you get your stuff together, you make sure your equipment is what you want, what you have.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know you're going to be going on a sea journey, a short one, across the Monmurian Straits to Helm's Island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Approximately how much time to take that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it like half a day?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, not even that at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Helm Island is maybe three, five miles away from the docks.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's right in the middle of the straits in between the Monmurg Peninsula and Flotsam Island, which is one of the outer islands.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not the biggest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fairwind Island is the biggest, but that's one of the islands of One of the Princes itself.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Helm Island kind of controls the strait because
[SPEAKER_02]: It's got lighthouses on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It basically tells people where Fairwind is, where Monmurg is.
[SPEAKER_02]: At night time, it's really important for the navigation of ships into the Monmurgian Bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And nowhere close where the dragon sea turtles kind of reside on the dragon isles?
[SPEAKER_02]: So here's the peninsula, here's Flotsam, or island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here's Helm Island in between the strait.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dragon Isles are way up here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, they're north of Flotsam Island, and probably I would say, I'm not going to give you an exact thing, but they're at least 40 miles away.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they're not near at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's at least a day's journey away, if not more.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway, you go down to the Royal Docks where there's a Cosaire that has been
[SPEAKER_02]: Loading up and getting ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: When you get down there, basically there are hundreds of marines that are loading up equipment, weapons, they've got their crossbows, they're wearing scale armor.
[SPEAKER_02]: 250, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Total?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's about how many they have on there, exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a small unit.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not a huge attack force.
[SPEAKER_02]: But obviously what's happening is Gian is trying to...
[SPEAKER_02]: But 250 is a pretty good complement.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's basically, we're checking this out.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're coming here to check things out.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's such that it would not be...
[SPEAKER_02]: An invasion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Consider it an invasion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do we have any, or did Lord Jameis give Paul anything that suggests what our role is for the captain of the Marine Force or the captain of the ship?
[SPEAKER_00]: You expect he talked to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: But basically what Lord Jameis wanted to say to you was that you're going as a representative of your uncle.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can basically bring Lord Fairwind to heel, because he's the guy that's in charge of the island.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so if there are any questions, basically you need to talk to Fairwind and say, what the hell's going on here?
[SPEAKER_00]: So you come with some consequence.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think this is Jon's way of introducing you into being a
[SPEAKER_02]: James hasn't given you guys any letters.
[SPEAKER_02]: The reason he hasn't given you a letter is because you're already Prince John's cousin, or nephew, and Fairwind, even though he doesn't really know the status you have, knows who you are.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who is Fairwind?
[SPEAKER_02]: So, remember, there are five princes in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's one of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is the prince of Fairwind Island, which is the largest island, but the one farthest away from Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he in charge of the helm?
[SPEAKER_00]: They rotate who's in charge of the helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay, so it's Fairwind's turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's the farthest away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So does he report to me, or do I report to him?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a prince.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, there's a council of princes.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is higher-ranked than you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, he's a prince of...
[SPEAKER_00]: But at the same time, Lord Jeon is more powerful than him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lord Jeon has more money.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lord Jeon is, the way it's said, he's the first among equals.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there's a...
[SPEAKER_00]: So when he says bring him to heel, if you have to, like, be respectful, but if you have to, push comes to shove.
[SPEAKER_02]: He doesn't want you to have conflict with this guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: He wants you to be able to say, look, are you okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Things are weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if things get weirder, you have authority to maybe do something.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Jeon wants to make sure that he's sending somebody that is going to tell him the truth about things and get to it.
[SPEAKER_02]: If Fairland acts weird towards you, if he says I'm not going to tell you what I'm doing or screw off what you could do to a captain or something,
[SPEAKER_02]: You can come back and say, well, it's strange, you should be able to speak your mind to me because I'm going to go talk to Gian about this and you better satisfy me because I'm not some underling you can just push around.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're just here to stand next to me and look cool and protect me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nobody knows what my job is.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've never, like, of some usual, like, how did I end up being muscle?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, actually I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know exactly how you ended up being muscle.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've blown up enough shit in my life that I have a reputation for blowing shit up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, and Jameis is worried about wizards.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Especially, like you said, the Toli assassins will use magic.
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he was like, you know, I need people that can take care of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me look up a spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, so, you guys get to the docks where the Cosaire is being loaded up.
[SPEAKER_02]: And a Cosaire is kind of a mid-sized war vessel.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three-masted, very fast.
[SPEAKER_02]: It doesn't have any catapults on it, but it has three ballistae on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And really the purpose of the Cosaire is to close with enemy ships and board them.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is kind of a pirate way of doing things.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the Corsairs are probably the fastest ships on the sea.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why Monmurg dominates, because several Corsairs will attack one larger ship if they know they can out-overwhelm them.
[SPEAKER_02]: If they can't, they just go away.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they can't be chased.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they're like wolves that attack lions.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's kind of the way they've been fighting the Keolanders for the last several decades.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway,
[SPEAKER_02]: The two of you are taken up to the ship and escorted to the top deck, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And basically you see the captain of the ship, it's obvious by what he's wearing, a breastplate, which indicates his rank with weaponry, and he motions to you to come up.
[SPEAKER_00]: I follow you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll go up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, you walk up to him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm standing, like, not necessarily beside him, but not right behind him.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, off to the right or left, but not parallel.
[SPEAKER_01]: A 45-degree angle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Something that's, like, not a follower.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not his body man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: But at the same time, you kind of look like his body man a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's your job.
[SPEAKER_00]: I still stand up at 45 degrees.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not leaning off the side of the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're trying not to look like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're trying to look more like a scribe than you are a body man.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that what you're doing?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I put a quail in my hair.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm making sure that I'm not obviously an elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, hood up or hair, whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you want your talk today?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean like, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to be wearing a hat?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, like a big brim hat.
[SPEAKER_02]: So without covering your face, people are gonna see that you're an elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're gonna know that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that anybody that sees you within 10, 15 feet are going to know what you are.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: But a person that's trying to snipe people, they're just going to notice the fact that you're in armored.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which, I don't know if that's good or bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ooh, it's a target!
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll have a big kind of cavalier type for him to keep the sun off.
[SPEAKER_02]: So anyway, you come up to the captain and the captain says, I am Captain Richard.
[SPEAKER_02]: I take it you are the nephew of Prince Gian?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Paul.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can tell by your mask.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you mind letting me know why it is that we have the
[SPEAKER_02]: The pleasure of your presence today.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am here to report personally to Geoland for what happened here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, I see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously, this guy is like, okay, I've got a manager here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would suggest you stay out of the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are welcome to stay on the upper deck with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you have any questions, please ask them.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, I do want to make it clear that I am in command of this endeavor.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I ever feel the need to, though, I have been given permission by Geon to take charge.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would not like to go to that, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I hope that we can remain on good terms.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, roll your persuasion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Negative two.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need like a ring or something though.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought I was bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen, okay, alright, that's uh... Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, alright, that's satisfying.
[SPEAKER_02]: Delivered a little roughly.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's delivered roughly, but it's truthful.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, and the guy is glad he's not having to hear it.
[SPEAKER_02]: In a more smarmy way.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he goes, very well.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll endeavor not to make that necessary.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you'll find that I'm quite a professional when it comes to commanding my men.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll see.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this guy is older, 35, and really...
[SPEAKER_02]: He's seasoned.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's seasoned, and you're like, okay, this guy is...
[SPEAKER_02]: Not gonna get his ego all bunched up.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's probably had this happen to him several times.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway, the marines get on board and by 3pm the ship is ready to go and they push off from the Royal Docks.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do the marines look like?
[SPEAKER_00]: He described them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Scale mail.
[SPEAKER_02]: Scale mail, shields, they have spears, they're carrying light crossbows.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are several of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: For a unit of, I'd say, 20 men, they have a captain or a sergeant who's in charge of what they are.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are two types of marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are also crossbow men marines that are in studded leather, lighter, but they're for the support with heavy crossbows.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they have heavier crossbows.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would say for every 20 frontline marine units, you have 10 of the crossbow guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: So sort of a two-to-one kind of mix.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So anyway, at 3 p.m., you ship off from the dock and begin sailing towards Home Island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What season is it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like in the sense, will it be dark when we come into the harbor?
[SPEAKER_02]: So Wealsun, I would say that to you Wealsun is kind of like March.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's still cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would say that sundown occurs this far south, however, more like around 730.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's probably going to take you an hour and a half to get there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you get to the place around 430,
[SPEAKER_02]: Five?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'll still be easy.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'll still be light.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'll have a couple hours of light before you have to worry about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, so you, Paul, the captain, the first mate who is piloting the ship, and one of the marine captains is up on the steerage deck as you head towards Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: When there's not obviously the flurry of maybe orders and commands being given as we leave the harbor, I wait until they're, you know, maybe 30 minutes out sailing and things have settled down into, you know, whatever routine.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just happen to say, I've never been to Helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: What kind of fortifications does it have?
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, the captain looks at me and he goes, well, there is the Helm itself, which is a, um,
[SPEAKER_02]: Medium-sized keep on the highest point of the island.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are several lighthouses, three, the east, the west, and the southern lighthouse, which will be sailing past first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then, of course, there are the quays, which are the docks on the backside of Helm.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's only one large fort.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, there are several
[SPEAKER_02]: Guard towers next to most of the lighthouses.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like bastions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, each of the lighthouses has a quay itself and some docks.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's where the largest fortification is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also, there is a large barracks that is in the middle of Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is surrounded by wooden palisades and it is down the hill from the Helm Fort itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: I try to make a mental note.
[SPEAKER_00]: Could it be that, and I'll have to ask for clarification, but just to the DM, if there were signals coming from the lighthouses, is there a lighthouse positioned that's actually closer, like that exists somewhere out on an atoll or whatever between Helm and the peninsula?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm trying to anticipate if there would possibly be...
[SPEAKER_00]: There is not.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact, the Peninsula of Monmurg has several lighthouses around it, and then the lighthouses on Helm are the ones that are between those two.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, there are several lightships.
[SPEAKER_02]: That basically show the way into the harbor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: But those are like barges that are basically tied together that do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So for any signals coming to Monmurg from Hell, are they delivered from the keep itself?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or are they delivered from outside of the keep?
[SPEAKER_00]: You asked the captain that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He said...
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm kind of including the lieutenant of the marines as well, like I'm looking and acknowledging.
[SPEAKER_02]: The captain says to you,
[SPEAKER_02]: Every one of the lighthouses has the capacity to signal.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact, they all have various ways to signal.
[SPEAKER_02]: They can change the color of the light.
[SPEAKER_02]: If it is red, they can say that they're under attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: From here, we cannot see the eastern lighthouse, so that would not be able to get a signal to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, a signal from the western lighthouse would go to the helm itself, and the eastern would be able to transmit that to Flotsam Island, if required.
[SPEAKER_00]: But any communication directly to Monmurg would come from the helm?
[SPEAKER_02]: It could.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is a very large tower in the helm, it is at the highest point, and it has several different braziers up there that can signal different things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: To the DM, was there anything suggesting, like, is this a standard marine force or is the captain suspecting, like, is the captain, to our knowledge, without asking him, was he made aware that there was some discrepancy with the signal?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have no idea what he was made aware of.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: 250 guys is a full contingent on a Corsair.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can pile on more, but this is not just a routine.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a battalion of guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's obvious the way they're moving and the way they're armed, they're expecting something.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is not a supply run.
[SPEAKER_02]: These guys are armed and they're ready to go.
[SPEAKER_00]: I suppose I asked why about these defenses.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we at risk being in the harbor at all while we investigate the helm, just to make sure that everything is functioning well and smoothly?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there any risk to the ship?
[SPEAKER_00]: At risk, what would you mean?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, we're going to investigate, you know, to make sure that Lord Farrowind has not suffered any difficulties or trouble.
[SPEAKER_00]: I kind of gestured to the, like, Marine compliment around.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, maybe they're not, like, obvious.
[SPEAKER_00]: They might just be sitting down.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're Marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going to make contact with Lord Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, that is true.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you know something I do not know?
[SPEAKER_00]: Other than contact with Lord Fairwind has been made necessary.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I assume that is your duty, correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: So if we are in the docks, the quays have several fortifications that are available.
[SPEAKER_02]: The quay walls are probably 30 feet high, and there are several hardpoints along the docks, as it were.
[SPEAKER_02]: Archers are usually based there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Up the hill, however, are the barracks.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, I assume the Quays are guarded.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are your marines allowed ashore at all once we dock?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or as procedure, are they kept on the ship?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, obviously we can't take a huge contingent up the hill.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is not an attack, an assault.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's an investigation.
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume what will happen is most of my men will stay on the boat and you, Lord Averro, will take a platoon with you and go up to Helm Island to see Fairwind and to question him on why he's been unable to correctly signal over the past several days.
[SPEAKER_00]: I might suggest that you have maybe some small squads of marines ready to intercept the hardpoints, should there be any catastrophic problems, which we are not yet sure of.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who is this man?
[SPEAKER_01]: He is... kick him in the shin.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is an advisor.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will do my job, sir.
[SPEAKER_02]: I expect you to do yours, whatever that job may be.
[SPEAKER_02]: Very well.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have no intention of assaulting hardpoints.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't say assault.
[SPEAKER_00]: I said to be ready to intercept, should there be a catastrophic problem.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you handle yours.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: I kind of just stroll away.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not pissed off.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just stroll away.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm getting the feeling there are things here that I do not know of.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just have your men ready to take action.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's all.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: He walks over to the Marine Captain and whispers in his ear.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And the Marine Captain salutes and then goes down the stairs into the barracks and starts shouting orders.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get the longboats ready!
[SPEAKER_02]: First and second platoon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Squad, be ready!
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, it's better to apologize than to have our corpses, like, eaten by, like, you know, the fishes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd rather, like, have to kneel and kiss the fucking rain and, like, you know... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so the hours go by, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: First and second squad.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you might want our council discretion.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just want to be ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: We just want to be ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just saying.
[SPEAKER_00]: On your own, later.
[SPEAKER_02]: Assemble on the deck.
[SPEAKER_02]: And this is a group of 20 men.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's our platoon?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, not yours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Platoon's 40.
[SPEAKER_02]: They come up for inspection.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there are 10 guys in the back road that are crossbow dudes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So 30 men get together, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: So everybody's actually pretty sharp.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go through inspection.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, these guys are professional.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want you to roll a perception check.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is a DC 15 perception check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I get any pluses?
[SPEAKER_00]: What's your perception ability?
[SPEAKER_00]: Perception plus three, so 16.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge is among the... Like wearing scale?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's wearing studded leather armor.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's one of the crossbow men.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's not wearing his usual stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's in disguise.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kind of.
[SPEAKER_02]: Supergouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, like, yeah, he's not young.
[SPEAKER_02]: But definitely you recognize him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to try to memorize faces to his right and to his left, especially if they're wearing certain leather.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anybody among the crossbowmen that are close to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if he's keeping them close, because I'm going to assume whoever's close to him are going to be his henchmen, just to kind of keep that in mind.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not aware of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and other than just looking to memorize some faces, I don't say anything, I don't try to nod, nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, so you sail forward, and after about an hour and 15 minutes, you guys come upon Helm Island, the west side of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the boat kind of turns towards the south,
[SPEAKER_02]: And the captain basically says to you, the docks are on the other side of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see the southern lighthouse sticking up probably about a quarter mile away.
[SPEAKER_02]: And next to it you see a tower, a wooden palisade basically that's maybe 40 feet high.
[SPEAKER_02]: A large structure.
[SPEAKER_02]: But not stone?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not stone, this is wood.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, the lighthouse has been out of stone.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is basically a defensive platform to make sure that anybody that comes on the docks tries to get up to where the lighthouse is will be attacked.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's overlooking where that small dock bay is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I notice any other hardpoints?
[SPEAKER_00]: How many, roughly?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are there two, three hardpoints?
[SPEAKER_00]: Meaning bastions?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not on this dock.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, this seems like a very simple dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: In a way, it's kind of like a little...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll draw on this piece of paper.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like here's the main island, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And this is like there's a bridge that has a sometimes beach between it and this other little outcropping that happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here's the quay and the docks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here is the lighthouse and the fortification kind of overlooks it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and this is the main island or the helm?
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the main island and you see the helm up there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, and the helm itself is the center.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's another lighthouse, the western lighthouse is over here connected by a
[SPEAKER_02]: And when I say sometime, beaches, sometimes islands, sometime beaches.
[SPEAKER_02]: Low tide, high tide?
[SPEAKER_02]: High tide comes up, and that water is clicked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right now, the tide is up, so there's no water.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the bridge is still, obviously, above the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you need to, and the bridge is stone, so if you need to, you can cross the bridge from place to place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fifteen more minutes go by, and the captain goes, First and Second Squad, investigate the Southern Lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_02]: So basically these guys lower these long boats, and they get in the water, and they take off and start rowing that way.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Corsair continues to swing around.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So only observable to—they're going to investigate this lighthouse, correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so a small boat's dropped as we—and then we kind of continue to come around.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the proper harbor area?
[SPEAKER_00]: You assume.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't really see anything there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and how many guys are going in?
[SPEAKER_00]: Two squads, 20 guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's going to be 30 guys going in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fifteen and fifteen per long boat?
[SPEAKER_02]: Pretty much, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they get in the water and go.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Corsair doesn't stop, and basically—
[SPEAKER_02]: Both of you can kind of tell he wouldn't have done this without what you had said.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So basically he's trying to make sure that he doesn't hit certain areas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he's making sure that he has the proper security.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's all that I wanted.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't want to get caught with our pants down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me neither.
[SPEAKER_00]: We got 250 Marines that get, like, sank.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sleeping on the boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, yeah, sleeping on the boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sank to the bottom of the harbor, caught unaware.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're all like, uh... Like I said, I would rather kiss the ring and apologize.
[SPEAKER_01]: Me and those, like, 30 Marines are going to have a last stand in some hallway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: So anyway, come around the side of the southern island, and you see
[SPEAKER_01]: Rocks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like a quay?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, basically there is like this area here where there are these
[SPEAKER_02]: Large basalt stones that come out of the ocean.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's not like you can sail through these.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they activate as a breakwater kind of.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eh, they're protecting of what it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here you see there's like an opening right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know how well that is, but you can see the quay and docks on here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this is kind of like the protected side of the island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: The lee side.
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's even further protected by these rocks here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you see the docks there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ships.
[SPEAKER_00]: Any other ships?
[SPEAKER_00]: Any flags on the ships?
[SPEAKER_02]: You see no ships.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in fact, the two of you see no men walking around on top of the quays or the fortifications that are over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that normal?
[SPEAKER_02]: I asked the captain.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's not normal.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would expect to see patrols here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You continue to sail around.
[SPEAKER_00]: You might take whatever further precautions you need necessary.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you nod?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, we're already thinking it's maybe, like, we're already getting, like, it's unusual.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so, and I basically just reinforced for him, like, whatever he thinks is necessary.
[SPEAKER_00]: We still have to land, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so you come around this way, and you see the Eastern Lighthouse Island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is very much like these other two.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, Stonebridge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, so he's not going in.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's actually gonna go drop off, maybe go drop off some more dudes?
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't see any docks on this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: But he might put out some rowboats.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So basically, though, he turns into the docks and comes in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, comes in that way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Towards the docks on that site.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can navigate this, but it actually seems to be a much more dangerous area.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's coming in in a safer way, but also he's coming in to avoid, let's say if there was a blister or something set up there or wherever.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's coming in to get the best view possible of what's happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: You actually like the way he's doing it, because he's coming around this way, making sure there are no ships over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, we triggered the cautionary principle for him, and he's attacking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not attacking.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's approaching this like there could be a fight.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's obviously looking at all possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: The only place he hasn't looked is over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please let us know if there's, and I motioned to Paul, let us know if there's anything more irregular to our untrained eyes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would expect patrols.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would expect at least one or two ships in the bay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which there are none, as I can see.
[SPEAKER_00]: And as you pointed out, no patrols.
[SPEAKER_00]: What else would you recommend that we do?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: The lighthouses are all lit though.
[SPEAKER_02]: They've not responded to our signals.
[SPEAKER_02]: Abandoned?
[SPEAKER_02]: The fires still burn.
[SPEAKER_02]: They were abandoned.
[SPEAKER_02]: They would go out.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would assume they would go out after several hours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Somebody is keeping the fires up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or they just packed up and left as soon as they saw us.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that we need to assume that if things are not as they appear, that things are probably... Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: In which case, are there any other precautions that you would take?
[SPEAKER_00]: The helm must be secured.
[SPEAKER_02]: I believe that we move forward with the plan that we've had.
[SPEAKER_02]: You, as a representative of Jian, will debark with a squad.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'll go to the beach and see if the harbormaster is anywhere to be seen.
[SPEAKER_02]: If not, I'll debark more men and we will look into the barracks.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you do see the men, we will cause no consternation among Lord Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, this is very strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good.
[SPEAKER_00]: We will proceed with all caution with any further recommendations that you might make.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you come into the dock and you come to the first dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are several of them over here, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And there are actual stairs that come up from two different locations.
[SPEAKER_02]: Along the quay...
[SPEAKER_02]: I would say every 100 feet, 120 feet, there is kind of a battlement that sticks out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like a hard point?
[SPEAKER_02]: Pretty much.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like a place that archers can stand on.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's the top level, which is level with the upper ground above the beach, maybe 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there are arrow slits in the second level.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just essentially hard points that can be defensible.
[SPEAKER_02]: And this beach is such that sometimes half of it is covered by water, sometimes it pulls out.
[SPEAKER_02]: The docks are such that they're whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: They are able to get to the beach every time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway, you pull into the docks and the captain
[SPEAKER_02]: Tells his Marine leader to get all the men ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: The guys basically arm up and they look on both the right and the left port side and the starboard side, crossbow men behind the spearmen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everybody's ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pretty much, yeah, on a high alert.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: He goes, third squad, disembark.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so basically...
[SPEAKER_02]: You dock, third squad disembark, and third squad throws down several ladders from the side of the boat, and men start getting off.
[SPEAKER_00]: So formally, I'd like to write it down, how many men in the squad, and are there any crossbow men in the group?
[SPEAKER_02]: In your group?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have pretty much ten men that are scale male guys, and then ten crossbow men.
[SPEAKER_00]: And ten crossbow?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lord Rivera, your squad awaits.
[SPEAKER_00]: He points down to them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to try to make sure that even though I'm talking a lot or asking a lot of questions, that as much as I can, I'm not stepping on Paul.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, so the two of you disembark from the ship, and as you walk down next to them, the sergeant salutes you and says, Sir!
[SPEAKER_02]: At ease.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll follow you in rank?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go look for the harbormaster.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do the crossbow men look ready, like crossbows drawn quarrels?
[SPEAKER_02]: I just want to notice because- They have not loaded their crossbows.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, but if they need to, that would have to come as an order?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you don't want to load a crossbow unless it's ready to fire, because you don't want it to sit there and just be, unless you're in combat.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just wondering if we get to shore, there's nobody to be found, no dock harbor, more marines are coming aboard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep your finger off trigger unless you're ready to destroy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just thinking, that's just personal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, as an aside, I kind of like saying a really low voice to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I say, flee, I hate that word.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if I say flee, it really just means get yourself hidden and fucking kill whoever it is that you can.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I say get the fuck out of here, I do like that word.
[SPEAKER_00]: That means get the fuck out of here because I don't know if I can like, you know, handle whatever it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the shit's gone really bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on, let's just go.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, repeat back to me, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Flee means hide and kill.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get out of here means get out of here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get the fuck out of here.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just worse than I thought.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on, let's go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stop it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that's fine, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: He doesn't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: He hasn't ventured with Bar Morgan Gouged before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Paul, how do you want to march?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to march next to the guys, behind the guys, or in front of them?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a great question.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on, Dad.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't wuss out.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I'm fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, we can't puss me out now.
[SPEAKER_00]: I said I, hello?
[SPEAKER_00]: I said that I would not step on you, so, you know, like your command.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I am good.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's just liking him.